our autumn and winter plan
always predicted that the cases would
rise around about now and
we're certainly seeing that in the in
the numbers we're seeing uh high levels
of infection but they're not outside the
the parameters of what was predicted or
uh what we we thought we'd see in the in
the autumn winter plan but it's very
important that people do follow the
guidance follow the guidance on
general behavior on being cautious on uh
wearing masks in confined places where
you're meeting people you don't normally
meet
wear a mask wash hands
ventilation all that kind of thing but
also
get your booster jab and that's the the
key message that we want to get across
that's why we've we've timed it for now
because you know there is some evidence
obviously that the
uh the vaccine starts to
wane
and
you get really very very good protection
uh with uh
the booster i mean a new new study says
about 95
protection so we're seeing the numbers
come up yesterday i think we did 250 000
across the country uh we want to see
them ramped up even further and thanks
to everybody for coming forward but we
need to to see a lot more on masks and
making sure that we wear them indoors in
the right settings should mps be leading
by example would you will you be leading
by example by wearing one in parliament
for example and are you going to have a
word with jacob rees-mogg who said that
tory mps don't need to do that because
they all know each other i think there
are lots of steps that we need to take
to to continue to follow the the
guidance so common sensical things
washing your hands wearing a mask in uh
confined spaces uh where you don't
normally meet other other people i think
where you're meeting people that you you
don't normally meet i should say um
that's that's sensible but the key
message for today is for all uh people
over 50s
think about getting your booster jab
when you get the call get the jab your
advisors on the sage committee say
boosters absolutely but to really get
case numbers down the big ticket measure
is advising people to work from home are
you ignoring their advice on that
we keep all
measures under constant review we'll do
whatever we we have to do to protect the
public but the numbers that we're seeing
at the moment are fully in line with
what we expected in the in the autumn of
winter plan
what we
want people to do is to come forward and
get their jobs we also want a young
people we want uh kids at school to to
be getting their jobs with complete
confidence and
they'll be booking systems uh opening
from tomorrow in addition to the
vaccination program in school so
the message is that the
the boosters are fantastic i mean the
the levels of protection are really very
high but it's also very very important
that you get one because the the double
vaccination provides a lot of protection
against uh serious illness and death but
it doesn't uh protect you against
catching the disease and it doesn't it
doesn't protect you against passing it
on so now is the time to get your
booster is there a strong case do you
think for reducing the time between the
second jab and booster from six months
to five i don't believe you're eligible
to have your booster yet you could be
soon if it was only five i know so look
i i say that's a very good question and
it's the important question i think a
lot of people are looking at that issue
and i i heard with great interest what
uh anthony hardin of the jcbi had to say
this of the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization had to say
this morning about that uh i think that
people should be coming forward uh with
the same
the same spirit of uh determination to
get their their boosters as we saw
earlier on uh this year uh it's a very
good thing to do because it gets you a
huge amount of protection and
we always expected that we would see
numbers rise right about now that is
happening and you've also got to take
into account the the waning
effectiveness of of the first two jabs
so get your boosters now
it's a full lockdown this winter with
stay-at-home advice shops closing is
that out of the question i i've got to
tell you at the moment that uh we see
absolutely nothing to to indicate that
that is that's on the cards if i may
just ask you her majesty the queen has
just left hospital do you have a message
for her having just left hospital would
you support her in not taking on too
much well i think everybody sends her
majesty that we send her our very very
best which is everybody does and uh
certainly certainly we have from the
from the government but i'm given to
understand that actually uh her majesty
is you know characteristically
uh back at her her desk at windsor as we
speak so
but we sent her every possible good wish